now to an issue that DW is covering
across the day gender-based violence
according to the United Nations every
hour five women are killed by members of
their own families today is the
International Day for the elimination of
violence against women the U.N is
launching 16 days of activism aimed at
raising awareness of what it says are
alarming rates of femicide where women
or girls are murdered because they are
women or girls the UN says 45 000 women
were killed by family members last year
alone the highest number was in Asian
countries followed by Africa but it's a
threat facing women around the world
in Germany around one in every seven
women experience rape or sexual assault
in their lifetimes but few instances are
reported because victims fear they will
not get adequate help from the police
and if cases do come to court only a
fraction and a conviction now an
initiative has been launched to help
reinforce cases against perpetrators of
sexual violence
it happens every day sexual assault rape
or severe injuries caused by
gender-based violence almost 10 000
cases were recorded by German police
last year but many cases likely go
unreported because the perpetrator is
often a partner or ex-partner and the
scene of the crime is often their home
[Music]
for example something of this nature
occurs in a family an instance of
domestic or sexual violence then people
are afraid of destroying social
structures of disturbing the family
peace
if it is reported then that can cause
huge problems within a family or within
existing Social Circles so people say
I'll just leave it
evidence of a sexual assault such as
sperm DNA on clothing or photos of
injuries must be secured as soon as
possible that happens automatically when
there is a police report but survivors
of rape often just want to forget what
happened and that can mean destroying
all traces of the perpetrator
in the Eastern German state of
Brandenburg as well as in other German
states more and more hospitals have been
taking a different approach for several
years now
without involving the police those
affected can have themselves examined
confidentially and anonymously by a
gynecologist or a urologist
hospitals have forensic medical tools to
secure evidence including clothing DNA
or photographs
that evidence is kept on file for 10
years
at the same time the women offered
immediate medical assistance and are put
in touch with victim counseling centers
this system is useful in cases of
re-traumatization so when the whole
thing happens again
the first time and even the second time
it happens I may not have wanted to
report it but maybe the third time I do
want to then it is possible to access
old cases so to speak in the current
context
fewer cases of rape in Germany are
reported than in other European
countries perpetrators often get off
scot-free the project wants that to
change even if survivors only have the
courage to go to the police much later
and there's lots to talk about on this
day for that I'm pleased to welcome
pinello she's the co-founder of feminite
map.org in Berlin a group of voluntary
researchers collecting data on
gender-based killings welcome to DW as
with all gender-based violence the
problem with femicides is that they are
heavily underreported isn't it how do
you go about collecting your data
yes exactly it's uh well thank you for
for having us here and we are not only
based in Germany we are online projects
so many of us are abroad but some of
other members are also in Berlin
um so the person the problem is not
recognized and therefore there is no
data and it's not reported as I mean
inside as such
um therefore we collect data from
newspapers uh that's of of our main
source of information we get to these
cases through Google Alerts uh and then
we present uh the cases that we get
every day through to this tool how many
cases have you been able to document
this year so far
these years so far uh we have collected
a 181 uh but we have to clarify that we
register all killings of women and
feminine sites because we want to see
also like what are the other patterns of
killing so it's not only about family
side but the mini sides we have recorded
so far 125 And to clarify also we we
consider family side not only as
intimate feminine side for intimate
feminine side cases we have registered
so far this year 86 cases and that would
be at the hands of a partner or former
partner
yes usually intimate feminine side is uh
Define us establish a couple that had a
sort of relationship okay this is a
tremendously important task you're
carrying out but shouldn't the
government be doing this
yes uh but it's uh like it has happened
in or it happens in many other countries
because the government first of all
don't recognize the problem it is the
work of activities uh or civil societies
work that perform this because it is all
the ones that are suffering and also the
ones that want to find solutions to this
so yeah it should be the definitely the
states but when the state not even
recognizes the situation as a problem as
is the case with Germany that for many
years it hasn't recognized it at all
then that's the first problem that we
are challenging and to what extent is
this an issue of framing you say it's
not really recognized as as a problem in
Germany for instance at domestic
femicides are often treated as A Private
Matter rather than a broader societal
issue
yes I think there are two things in
these questions the first one is like
the framing and the importance of naming
this uh this crime as such because for
instance
um the German government has for
instance denied to collect data on
feminine site under the skills that
since it is not a criminal category in
Germany therefore they don't have the
the power to record uh the numbers and
also because the Istanbul convention
does not address concretely familiar
sites they also kind of excuse of not uh
registering these cases which from our
perspective is uh it's not even an
argument
um and the other one is like framing
familiar sites or domestic uh related
killings that I would call it intimate
feminine sites as an individual problem
is also a problem because then you erase
the structural and societal aspect of
the problem it is true that is also
there is responsibility from the
individual but also from the from the
society when we as a society accept this
problem or Justify the problem say like
okay it's because this woman was in a
relationship with this person or is
because this woman accepted the violence
in the first place it's her fault then
we are this is the societal after topic
that the researchers in communities that
are speaking about
femininemap.org thank you so much for
your time
thank you
an impunity for the perpetrators of
gender motivated violence is especially
high in the context of war and armed
conflict the United Nations says between
10 and 20 cases go unreported for every
case that is documented the latest
available figures from 2021 show more
than 3 000 documented cases of sexual
violence during conflict but the UN says
the true figure is more likely 30 to 60
000 or even higher
let's bring in Christina Lam she's an
award-winning British journalist and the
chief foreign correspondent for the
British newspaper the Sunday Times she's
also published 10 books including our
bodies their Battlefield what war does
to women an account of how violence
against women is used as a weapon of War
around the world Ms Lamb welcome to the
day we talk a lot about missiles and
bombs when we talk about weapons of war
but sexual violence is older than all of
them combined what role does rape play
in war and conflict
well there's always been rape in War I
mean if you go back to ancient Greeks
and Persians and Romans there was always
rape but what we've seen in recent years
is much more the use of rape as a weapon
of War where soldiers uh militias are
instructed to deliberately go and rape
the women
rape though right it's also sexual
slavery forced marriage forced pregnancy
what does all of that do to women and
girls
well unfortunately the reason that we're
we're seeing it happen so much and I
mean if you just look back the last
eight years there's so many cases you
look at the what happened to the ucds in
Iraq enslaved by Islamic State Fighters
uh the rohingya people in Burma or
Myanmar who uh the Burmese militia
military came into their Villages and
gang raped the women and also women in
Nigeria like the two book girls who were
taken from their school in the middle of
the night abducted by Boko Haram
Fighters just the tip of the iceberg
that was happening to tens of thousands
of women in the region so you know there
are hundreds of thousands of cases
there's really an epidemic of it but the
fact is that unfortunately it's a very
effective weapon if you want to
terrorize a population humiliate them uh
make them leave an area it is a very
effective way of doing it and it's also
very cheap one militia said to me it's
cheaper than a Kalashnikov bullet you
have extensively reported from Ukraine
since Russia's Invasion how widespread
is rape in this war
when I first started getting reports
early on in the war from female
activists in Ukraine I really found out
how to believe I didn't think that the
Russians would be doing that but then
soon you know there were so many reports
it was clear that it was happening on a
wide scale and when the Russians left
Butcher and European around Kiev I went
and talked to people in those areas
Villages around and heard many really
shocking reports from women of what the
Russians had done
um and a lot of people are reluctant to
report it but it certainly happened and
it continues to happen I believe they're
on a large scale and it's very
reminiscent of what the Red Army did in
Germany actually at the end of the
second world war during the liberation
of Berlin when they came in and raped a
really large number of women
the ICC has prosecuted only two cases of
rape in its 22 years that added to the
fact that Russia is not a signatory to
the Rome statute how big are the chances
that the people ordering and carrying
out these atrocities will be brought to
Justice at some point
well this is the real problem I mean
raping Warriors or International War
crime but it is the most neglected War
crime and accountability as you just
mentioned with the ICC at the moment is
the exception not the rule almost no
perpetrators are brought to book for
what they have done but the one sort of
positive if you could say that about
Ukraine is that there for the first time
has been really widespread reporting on
the issue and there's a lot of outrage
and the International Community is very
active the international criminal court
have got people working their president
zielinski has spoken about the rape in
the same breath as the torture and
killing whereas too often in conflicts
we've seen rape kind of regarded as a
side issue as somehow not so important
to be prosecuted is the as other things
that are happening so I think you know
maybe just maybe this might be a sort of
Turning Point where people really take
it seriously in a way that hasn't been
before
what to me and and I think after reading
your book to you as well is very
disturbing is how quickly these
atrocities are committed when there are
no social and disciplinary restraints
guiding our coexistence that the
darkness seems to lie very closely under
the surface how do you explain this the
flipping of the switch in a way
yeah I mean it's hard to find a conflict
where it hasn't happened so uh it does
make you wonder you know if people are
in this situation uh men because it is
almost always been carrying out these
acts is there some something latent that
leads them to to do this but I think the
real problem and all of the women that I
spoke to uh survivors the one thing that
they all really want is Justice and that
doesn't necessarily mean seeing the
perpetrator in court it might mean just
acknowledgment of what has happened to
them because the perhaps the most
heartbreaking thing about all of this is
this is a crime where the victim is
often made to feel that they've done
something wrong and that they are then
ostracized from their Community not able
to talk about what happened to them just
as in Germany at the end of this second
world war many of the women committed
suicide rather than actually talk about
it to this day that situation continues
and even in Ukraine not that many people
actually have really officially reported
to the prosecutor people have spoken to
the hotlines but they haven't made
official reports
journalist and author Christina Lamb
pleasure speaking to you tonight
thank you
sexual harassment in public spaces is
also a problem for women and girls
around the world including in Mexico
women there are also frequently subject
to coercive control from their male
Partners in one District of Mexico City
activists are getting organized with
Street patrols to raise awareness of
these problems
for over a decade Rosario's husband
controlled every aspect of her life her
finances when she could leave the house
even which clothes she was allowed to
wear the abuse almost drove her to
Suicide her story is All Too common in
Mexico where 3 out of 10 women suffer
psychological violence
[Music]
it even affected my physical appearance
I didn't care anymore how I dress or if
I bathed because my husband would ask me
why I dressed up or why I took a bath he
was very jealous
Rosario went to an official refuge for
survivors of violence in Mexico City
where she lives
the local government has built 13 of the
houses which have helped over 8 000
women in the past year alone
but it's not always easy to ask for help
some women are afraid their neighbors
will see them enter a safe space and
mark them as victims
this District organizes daily Street
patrols to discourage stigmatization and
raise awareness of Institutions that
protect women
okay
the environment is also part of the
problem the authorities have improved
Street Lighting on several main Avenues
to create safe paths for women
nearly three quarters of all harassment
and other sex crimes happen in the
street and on public transport
almost half of Mexican women say the
fear of sexual violence has made them
stop taking walks visiting relatives and
friends or even going to school
one man was masturbating right in front
of me others brush up against you when
they walk past we can ask for help but
no one does anything
one time I became paralyzed with fear
and now I can't take the Subway by
myself I'm afraid I could freeze again
at any moment
violence against women is recurrent and
widespread but Rosario is using her
voice to fight it so her 12 year old
daughter can live freely
for more I'm very pleased to welcome
Anita Bhatia she is the Deputy executive
director of un women and joins us now
from New York thank you so much for
taking the time according to a recent
report that you've published the biggest
threat to women is posed by the men that
they know well it's often the men that
they live with what needs to change so
that men stop assaulting and killing the
women in their lives
well as you noted most perpetrators of
what we call intimate partner violence
are men so actually we have to start
with the men and we have to start
educating them but more importantly we
have to start to change attitudes and
cultural norms and behaviors which
normalize this the issue is that Society
has a very high tolerance for violence
against women so unless we change
people's attitudes and they begin to see
this for the crime that it really is
nothing much is going to change so how
do you go about doing that and what
would your message be for example for
the men who are watching this interview
right now
well first of all I would say it is a
human rights violation so violence
against women any kind of violence is
actually not just abuse it is a human
rights violation so if you are indulging
in that kind of behavior you are
violating that woman's human right the
second thing that I think is really
important is that we have to keep
advocating for the importance of
tackling this issue as a public policy
priority the problem is that for most
governments this isn't a big enough
priority yes on days like the
international day to end violence
against women you will have public
figures speak up about it today they'll
speak up about it over the next 16 days
because we have a campaign for 16 days
but it is actually got to be something
that's discussed in government in
cabinet and it has got to rise to the
level of a national priority so that
there are resources allocated to it and
it is something that is viewed as a
universal problem and not just an
individual house sort problem that has
to be faced by the woman who's the
victim of abuse and the U.N has
recognized that the overall number of
femicides has remained largely unchanged
over the past decade what is going wrong
there
well there are a couple of things
happening first as I said Society has
really normalized violence against women
people are no longer a shot enough about
it to want to take action the second
thing that's happened is that during the
pandemic there was a huge exponential
rise in violence against women and it
became visible during the pandemic our
Secretary General called it the shadow
pandemic but a post-pandemic those raids
of violence continue to remain high and
the third thing that has happened in the
last couple of years is that the number
of conflicts in the world and the number
of countries in the world where there is
a huge pushback against women's rights
has gone up so whether it's Afghanistan
or Iran or what's happening but the
conflict in Ukraine you see women
suffering because they are in the front
lines of either conflict or protesting
against oppression of their
and so that is associated with the right
right a rise in the rates of violence
so these are intertwined issues
requiring
urgent responses Anita Bhatia I want to
thank you so much for joining us on DW
news to speak about these questions
thank you